hi there steve here again uh i want to
continue on the theme that i started the
last uh
video cast
where i talked about
uh
forgetting languages and how we're able
to keep languages
in our heads and how we forget them and
so forth
um
and i will then speak a few other
languages like i did the last time i i
ended up speaking a little bit of german
um so i claim to speak 11 languages i
must admit my
russian and portuguese are not nothing
to be so proud of but i do understand
podcasts and i can communicate
in them
um
which languages do i have the best grasp
on certainly my strongest four
are english french japanese and mandarin
and i think the reason for that is that
i have spoken them more
than the others
so
it's clear to me that in order for the
languages to stay in our brain we have
to use them we have to speak them
uh
i wasn't
so strong on that before but i do
believe that to be the case now we don't
have to speak them all the time to
maintain them but in order to
achieve a level where we are not likely
to easily forget them we have to at some
point
be involved in using them a lot
and
so this may sound a bit contradictory
because i have said that
we learn primarily through listening and
reading i very much believe in input
based learning that's always how i have
learned my languages
but what that does is it takes you up it
builds up your potential in the language
but then at some point you have to use
the language to really get good at it my
russian is now at a stage
where if i were
with a bunch of russians for an extended
period of time if i lived in russia for
six months
my russian would get very good
the same is true of my portuguese
and i might add the same is true of
some of my other
minor languages if english french
japanese and mandarin are the strongest
then the next group would be probably
german swedish and spanish
which i've used to some degree
and then the italian and the cantonese
and and i can't remember what i forgot
they would be you know less strong as
portuguese and russian
but i could get them up i have enough
exposure enough vocabulary in all of
them that if i were in italy for three
months solid using the language or spain
or
russia then i could get them to a point
where i wouldn't easily lose them
but right now if i'm away from spanish
yeah i'm going to struggle a third
person
past or whatever get a lot of things
wrong sometimes be looking for words
which doesn't happen to me in japanese
french or mandarin
[Music]
[Music]
i want to bring this subject up because
i think the speaking like when do we
need to speak there are the purists
who say
that uh you know there is a fellow in
thailand who has a
language learning system called alg
uh i don't remember what that stands for
automatic language guru or something i
don't remember
but his thing is that for the first year
his students are not allowed to speak
thai and i think that's extreme because
people it's very hard to police
so so why have a system that's so hard
to police people are going to want to
try out what they've learned
however there is an argument that says
that you can damage your
accent pronunciation or even your
phraseology by starting to speak too
early i'm not sure if that's true
but i i think you don't need to speak
early but there comes a point where you
need to speak and you need to speak a
lot in order to really ingrain the
language so
to summarize i don't think there's a
need to speak at an early stage or you
can speak a little bit just to maintain
your interest level
sometimes to test out where your gaps
are
but at some point
you're gonna say okay i have now built
up a sufficient potential in this
language i understand the language i
read it i have lots of words now i want
to really forge that into my brain well
at that point you've got to spend a lot
of time speaking in order to really
become comfortable in the language and
once you've achieved that then it's
harder to forget the language
so
you know within my languages you know i
like i haven't spoken i spoke quite a
bit of portuguese when i was in portugal
but i haven't spoken any russian this
evening i have my first
opportunity to speak russian with rasana
after an absence of
five six months five six weeks from the
language
yeah so i've got to get on link i got to
do more reading i haven't done anything
on my russian but i understand it i put
on uh some ecommerce podcast no trouble
i think it'll take me a couple of days
and i'll be right back to snuff um
portuguese
now i'm going to confuse it with russian
because i'm going into a part of my
brain that's for new languages in other
words i do believe as i said earlier on
this how the brain learns that things
that are ingrained comfortably nice
habits nice patterns that the brain is
comfortable with are on one side of your
brain
and the new stuff is still kicking
around in another part that hasn't quite
moved over to where it's a comfortable
pattern so if i'm now trying to speak a
little bit of russian and then
portuguese and neither of them are very
strong i'm i'm kind of competing for the
same
neuro neural space there
[Music]
so i'm just showing my
struggling in some of these languages
but but the fact that you struggle in a
language that's
you know
we're still a large part of it is in
that
novelty side of your brain that's not a
problem
and but ultimately if i wanted to secure
portuguese then i would go i would have
to go there for three or four months or
six months but i can still keep up
you know building up my potential in
portuguese
without having the opportunity to speak
a lot and i do that through my
deliberate vocabulary accumulation
listening and reading so i'm getting
stronger and stronger and the stronger i
am
the better i do when i go there and
that's why i feel that
that one goes to the country
when you don't have a very good level in
the language you go there to stimulate
you to get you turned on so that you'll
put the effort in
to do a lot of listening and reading
or you build yourself up through a very
heavy sort of input based program
so that when you then go to the language
you can really take advantage so that
you can actually start to talk to people
and you can then
progress very very quickly so my
recommendation in terms of going to the
country to learn is
build yourself up first so that when you
get there you can really take advantage
i've seen too many people come to
vancouver to learn english and they just
hang around with their friends and
really their english doesn't improve
very much
so that's kind of what i had to say on
forgetting and learning languages i
don't know if it made sense but i look
forward to your comments thank you